oui nous avons décidé de fermer la
campagne ce matin ici ici parce que on
comptait
montré une des conséquences de la
canicule
à savoir la déformation naturel physique
depuis que le monde est monde des
matériaux a fait très chaud mais comme
notre société était réputée être une
société en zone tempérée elle ne
connaissait rien à ces situations qui
sont le lot quotidien d'une bonne partie
de l'humanité depuis fort longtemps j'ai
appris à s'en protéger pendant ce temps
nous n'avons rien appris du pin aucune
circonstance et alors même que la
sécheresse et la canicule sont des
phénomènes très étroitement liés au
changement climatique que les alertes
ont été donnés largement à temps puisque
peut-être vous en souvenez vous j'avais
essayé de démarrer ma campagne
présidentielle sur le thème de la
perturbation du cycle de l'eau rien n'a
été fait à l'heure à laquelle nous
parlons le gouvernement a prévu un
numéro vert et des crédits alors c'est
plus un gouvernement c'est une cabine
téléphonique et et des crédits pour
distille re naturalisé la ville
c'est-à-dire y mettre des arbres ce qui
est entre le ridicule et l'absurde qu
est-ce qu en cette période on plantera
pas d'arbres ça n'est pas le moment ça
se fête et puis parce que c'est pas du
tout ce qui est attendu ce qui est
attendu c'est premièrement que l'urgence
soit assumée et l'urgence c'est d'abord
avant tout le fait d'être certain que
tout le monde puisse avoir accès à de
l'eau potable
sans qu'il lui en coûte davantage que
d'ouvrir son robinet je dis ça parce que
très vraisemblablement dans toute une
série de communes du pays ou bien il
faudra amener de l'eau potable ou bien
il faudra que les gens est taxé à 2
fabriquer de l'eau en bouteille et je
veux signaler que d'ores et déjà il se
pose un problème c'est que cette eau en
bouteille selon lui à augmenter
l'urgence et modifier immédiatement
prendre les dispositions concernant les
gens qui travaillent en effet le centre
qui s'occupe de la prévention des
accidents du travail
et de la santé au travail a d'ores et
déjà fait des recommandations sur les
températures maximum suivant que l'on
est sur un chantier entraînèrent ou dans
un bureau c'est entre 28 et 33 de toute
façon si tu es nous voulons rappeler aux
travailleurs qu'ils ont tous un droit de
retrait dès lors qu il exerce dans
respect du code du travail mais là c'est
une situation de mise en danger de même
le code du travail impose aux patrons
et puis ce qui organise le travail de
devoir assurer aux travailleurs l'accès
à de l'eau potable pour pouvoir se
désaltérer et pouvoir se mettre à
l'ombre à intervalles réguliers pour ne
pas subir la chaleur comme vous le savez
des mesures d'exception déjà été prises
enceinte un département où l'on a décidé
que les jeunes gens les enfants n'iront
pas à l'école parce qu'il me fait trop
chaud tout ça c'est l'urgence l'immédiat
le pour tout de suite
les 500 millions prévus pour naturaliser
les russes on est venu naturellement
mais pourquoi ne pas s'inspirer aussi de
ce qui se fait dans les pays où est ce
que je suis pour et notamment en
installant dessus des rues qui sont
devenus du véritable brasier dit vélum
une étoile de cette nature qui sont le
principe le plus simple que l'on n'ait
pu trouver depuis que le monde est monde
qui est de faire de l'ombre ça sent
moins chaud donc ces techniques là elles
sont à portée de tout le monde et puis
ça nécessite maintenant dès qu'on
commence à réfléchir et pas seulement
réussir mais a décidé il y à des
constructions depuis des siècles qui se
contentent bois terre paille qui sont
beaucoup plus frais que le béton est
naturellement plus pratique c'est
immense verrière qui ont été ou frites
partout sous lesquelles on se gèle
pendant l'hiver il faut nous surchauffée
et où on est tous en était donc
les climatisations bref tout ça c'est
pour une fois de plus faire que cette
campagne puisse être utile à quelque
chose dans l'esprit du bambou le monde
est en train de changer radicalement
du fait du changement climatique le
changement climatique est irréversible
comme nous ne cessons à quelques uns ici
de le dire depuis déjà quelques années
donc il faut s'y adapter il ne faut pas
croire ceux qui comme monsieur macron et
compagnie pense que le marché va régler
le problème de la canicule
puisque s'il ne fait rien c'est qu'il
compte que quelque chose se passe pour
lequel y aura bien besoin de faire et ça
se réglerait tout seul la réponse au
manque d'eau ce n'est pas acheter de
l'eau en bouteille c'était en sorte
qu'on cesse le gaspillage qu'on cesse
les mésusages et que on traite la nature
de manière plus respectueuse de ses
cycles pour reconstituer le cycle de
l'eau etc malheureusement personne ne
peut savoir ce que sera cette planète et
notre pays tempérés d'ici quelques mois
il est absolument certain que dès le
mois de septembre et d'octobre nous
aurons comme on dit à lyon des épisodes
cévenols et comme on dit dans le grand
sud et épisode méditerranéen
c'est à dire des trombes d'eau vont
s'abattre sur le littoral pour la raison
que la mer méditerranée ces rapports
plus vite que les autres mers et océans
du monde et déclenché de cette manière
de terrible à bâle en judo vis-à-vis de
laquelle le sol et des constructions ne
sont absolument pas préparés cet été les
gens pour avoir pouvoir vont avoir très
chaud des gens vont avoir besoin
d'accéder à l'hôpital mais 120 services
d'urgence sont fermés des maisons dont
quatre étaient celles qui sont
installées sur des terres de glaise
évidemment la glaise se rétracte en bas
les maisons qui sont prospères de suite
vont pas très fort derrière et la
plupart des transports ferroviaires et
aux doit être perturbés par le
réchauffement des matériaux qui servent
à rouler leur ipad enfin il est à peu
près certain que le nucléaire va tomber
en panne à peu près partout pour la
raison qu'on n'a jamais refroidi ou
salle centrale nucléaire au monde avec
de l'eau chaude ça n'existe pas
déjà il y à une tranche qui est fermée
et il y en aura d'autres parce que le
débit du rhône à baisser le débit de
plusieurs des grandes rivières de ce
pays baisse et le fonctionnement de la
centrale
réchauffer la rivière je pense que de
cette manière il ya un débat qui clôt le
nucléaire
énergie intermittente pour que plus en
terme tant que les éoliennes en mer qui
elles sont plus constants voilà ce que
le signal que nous voulons lancer le
monde change et cette fois ci il s'agit
pas simplement de la motte il s'agit pas
simplement d'un process de production il
s'agit de ce casque est fondamental
l'environnement l'éco système dans
lequel la vie humaine est possible dès
lors la politique doit se réclame et non
pas de recette miracle et nous avait
existé mais aujourd'hui vont être jamais
elle doit se réclamer de principe c'est
à dire quelle que soit la situation quel
est le principe rom et en oeuvre
aujourd'hui nous avons la réponse des
macros nist quand ils se donnent mal de
perdre loire nous dire quelque chose à
prendre des injures et bien la réponse
est le marché ça va s'arranger tout seul
suivant que vous avez des moyens au
moment de faire face les moyens
financiers à la situation la note de
répondre réponse c'est celle de
l'entr'aide de la solidarité est ce que
nous pouvons dire est que moi je
terminerais là dessus c'est que dans la
nouvelle période il faut entrer avec des
principes fermes et la politique du
gouvernement la politique de l'état doit
être fermement ancrée autour de
principes qui permettent de se voir où
l'on va voilà j'espère que ce petit
instant aidera à la prise de conscience
de la réalité que nous allons désormais
bio quoi qu'il arrive si nous sommes
majoritaires dimanche je comprends que
le jeu adversaire soit de faire croire
que c'est impossible mais la statistique
et les réalités électorales ne sont pas
aux ordres de boucher macron ils
resteront mois se trompent désobéissance
c'est celui de la réalité et donc si
nous sommes majorité majoritaire
dimanche soir lundi nous allons nous
occuper de tout ça dès la première heure
pour tâcher de faire en sorte qu'ils
sortent le moins mal possible de la
canicule et de ses méfaits sur guppy
merci pour votre attention
[Musique]